first of all
congrats on the movie it's going to be a
big hit families are going to love it
uh i i had a lot of fun with it um now
getting into why i get to talk to you
true or false
you only did this movie because you
wanted the jack and rose lamp
false i thought that was a great
addition
um uh being serious for a second um
you started acting at a young age and
you successfully made the transition
from like
young actor to being an adult without
sort of the paparazzi and
walking down some sketchy paths um who
do you credit with like
keeping you on that on the right path
and or was it sort of just
yourself you didn't you know what i mean
yes i do know what you mean
um i mean i think uh there's a
lot of reasons um
i have always known that i wanted to be
an actress like
i don't remember a time where i that
wasn't just
what i wanted to do i never want to
jeopardize
being able to do that so that kind of
like
kept me from going anywhere like
darker you know like like i didn't
shave my head or i mean you look great
that was a
i love you
like when i was in my angstius teen like
you know i i like dyed it with like
vegetable dye to
like be dark dark hair but i would never
like
do anything that couldn't be undone
right away in case an audition came up
um and so that was just always something
that was so
present with me and um
and then i think it also helped that i
wasn't really that successful as a kid
like i i kind of worked but very
sporadically
and you know even when i thought like oh
great this is gonna be it it wasn't and
so
so i that just kept kept me like
um humble i guess
and uh yeah i just i think
i think it was just the i never want to
like
i'm a rule follower i don't want to like
i don't want to get in trouble
i don't want to like i just want i just
wanted to
work no i can i completely get it um
this movie jumping into the film this
movie does not work
without uh matilda i mean and she did
such
she did such a great job um can you sort
of talk about maybe what surprised you
about working with her and because
it's hard to deliver the performance
that she has to deliver
absolutely i mean that was such a relief
that that you know the heavens clearly
opened up and
and dropped matilda in into this part
because
it she is extraordinary in every way
she's so naturally talented and
she's so professional like i i
i really do believe she's she's like
probably 75 and um she's fooling us
all because she is that good and
she is she's just she's remarkable in
every way
and and that that
was everything that and the cgi and
making ulysses look so incredibly
realistic
and so adorable and i just i need
i need a ulysses in my life
like i said um uh people are really
going to enjoy this movie
i'm curious if behind you is where you
do all the magic that you've learned
from working with penn teller well
if you think crafting is magic then yes
this is my craft room
and it's my happy space um and so
i'm sure i could craft a magic trick but
uh
it we i would never like think
it was good enough to show ben and tell
her i am curious though because you've
seen a lot of magic tricks
uh being a part of that show can you
actually do any magic tricks now
is it something that you've sort of like
been like i want to learn this
um i mean teller has taught me several
tricks
and um and he's so patient and
it's really it's hard to sort of like
concentrate when he's doing that because
the whole time i'm like tyler's teaching
me a trick
um so and he taught my daughters their
first
magic trick so like forever i have that
and uh or they have that and um
uh but it's it's just such a talent that
um that everybody has and it's such a
world that
that is it's so different and i love
being the audience member
for that completely um listen congrats
on the movie again
please take home the jack and rose thing
ask them for it and
uh have a great day thank you you too